hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play
dishonored you know I realized since my
webcam isn't here I could play
completely naked that's right ladies
I am completely naked while playing
right now hey sorry guys anyway
so we're going to get rid of this so
called high overseer whatever while at
the same time saving the life of a one
uncle of some hot lady hello mister and
I'm going to be so stealthy so beyond
still sees damn you remember this a
basket haha
goodness it hit that buttocks you didn't
see anything just gonna get out my
weapon oh I have a power that can do
this can I don't I I do right you
should we gather for whiskey and cigars
tonight never doubt
no now is much better uh-huh listen
downright lovely OOP hope you didn't see
anything man - where am I going
ah I see oh yeah that's right foot whoop
quick x-men you look really up yeah oh
like a shadow in the night and I don't
jump across these cuz that apparently
hurts like a boss or not like a boss
that hurts like us like a son of a [ __ ]
Boosh Tom Irv cows a totally unnecessary
work I'm a shadow of the night oh yes he
came right up to me yeah you saw it he's
good no oh go go go come on
oh that's not good oh yeah ha ha I block
that What Huh What huh oh oh come on
come on
Wow I'll block it work the foul yep yep
ah he's not stealthy at all I know what
do you want me a job they came right at
me
look yeah oh look about ok anyway so
take care of and old Oh and the body's
so neatly stacked I've had at this what
do you expect my first time
you know I'm I'm totally used to playing
these types of games
Boop
all right okay now back on track wait
where am I going
well it doesn't help me at all yeah come
up here uh then we go over there they
don't wanna oh you wish no okay step
foot Jack house black shadow of the
night
why is it not on bottle street if what I
hear is true are you guys walk there at
night on account of slack jaws upgrade
you didn't see anybody
yeah ah like a shadow in the night found
super secret awesome way in wait a
minute
yeah super secret hahaha some phone
goodbye what who found what now oh come
on no run away I was like a shadow in
the night
I'm a shadow in the night shadow in the
night
yeah shadow night it's got him in the
arse crap anyway it's his fault if he
catches us in here told you about word
times Campbell is upstairs meeting with
the captain of the watch he'll be busy
for hours okay keep looking and I've
told you 100 times
Roger that I am certain it keeps the
black book on his person at all times we
went to the trouble breaking into
Carroll sanctum for nothing okay listen
what was that nothing anyway hopefully I
lost those guys out there obviously
black box
that graphic was really rather rather
graphical okay so what was this about a
so called ah this away probably know
you get off this time yeah that's right
you didn't wanna mess me anyway okay so
obviously I've done bad ah don't do
anything uh I need a distraction
I need like a bottle or something no we
don't you don't shut up
you don't know oh crap why did I do that
ah doozy thing ah like a shadow in the
night out of a shadow there no ah you
don't see me cuz I'm like a shadow uh-oh
ah crap yeah get me up there
give up that look oh no I'm dead
okay okay I'm did so did Wow like shadow
oh hey wait try that uh one more time oh
come on Hart so let's just all right
like shadow in the night no no that
fifth tip it sounds pain it does you
ever seen the ritual I've never seen the
heretics brand used it's a rare
occurrence but I did spy the face of one
so yes on a retreat
two official test sign yeah you scroll
action so you know I'm a stop specific
members or even the high office how much
dry violates our kono I could get up is
like you get on that roof somehow what
is that the seven eyes actual oh I will
how will you brother you won't do no oh
wait no wait no ah I can wrap around
there then I can sneak around yes yes oh
no that's not right
no how do I know huh okay yeah it's down
here
Oh way down huh you'll find me
yep yeah you didn't see anything hey I'm
still feel a cab out anyway how do i how
do I kick again Tommy I forgot how to
kick yeah melee weapon anyway what's
this secret supplies bolts oh yeah wait
was it got chain oh so great I'm so
great I can't even handle it how great I
am
okay ah this looks more like it
that is safe over there look like a seat
no that's just a door to the kennels I
don't go the kennels I don't I want to
go to the kennels ah crap
ah come on how did this help me it
doesn't help me at all
it helps me none back over here I need
to get up I need to get up there I can't
get up there [ __ ] just increase the
range of my jumpy juice oh all right
let's go in here and listen to the
secret conversation I don't see
Campbell's Journal anywhere
this is oh I know if he catches us in
here I've told you I doctored you a
hundred times
thank you I should lay some traps
Oh grub on foo I know what to do I know
what to do with that alarm I need to hit
it and get out is that way the door
opens and I run away like a mouse yes
perfect now the doors are open and now I
can get in Oh cry it was didn't work at
all
we gotta get up how do I get up there oh
yeah Oh guys didn't do anything
hahaha holy come on nope
no okay I'm trying this again going this
way now
yeah like boss oh what's that oh you
can't get me huh no surprise there
oh how is that route
ah where'd you come from ah crap alright
fighting time nuts messing around
ow little more messing around please no
oh you shot me you shot me
well this is just failure across the
board all right no more [ __ ] around I
know what to do your rooftops and edges
you believe it baby boom Who am I the
cattles oh yay
I'm over here good good got me a little
closer I'm nowhere and everywhere what's
down here
oh that's that
look that house is it not on what I used
your guards can't even walk the rebound
time turn hard work it up there how do I
get up there alright anyway I'm gonna
try to get a cross it doesn't help me at
all oh how do I get across there you
don't see anything buddy stop looking
over here jack house
yeah so stealthy so stealthy it's kind
of unreal
I check out over here there was hello
okay now here now what I meant here Wow
did I ever mention I'm a bit out of
practice with these stealth element
games honesty was it's gotta be way up
on that ledge I know there is oh come on
didn't see thing huh no oh come on oh
don't make me die again that's what I
thought cut ah go to the backyard that
sounds good yeah it's right there yeah
yeah climb to reach higher locations
don't tell me that out of the way you
expect preferential treatment just
because you are her brother she will
burn all witches must burn right I
should probably save this person to
silent you're lying top of the tower
which table uh uh-huh yeah oh come on
you're welcome you appeared as if from
nowhere we would both be dead if not for
you damn straight or forever in your
debt
I cannot thank you enough oh you must
have yeah my sister to safety
okay I may know her way to thank you
here's a safe in the bunkhouse the
combination is 2:03 yay what you want
yes
you're welcome ah well now isn't this a
surprising turn of events what's going
on ah Bob come so bad at this all right
here we go by looking good what that
hurt Oh too bad
Oh No uh uh wha
Wham yeah get him rats
right back to being like about all right
doesn't matter I'm right here oh come on
oh okay I got it here need key oh maybe
that guy had the key
I don't need the key yep earnest ever
knew yep back about Luna our bone charm
nearby oh hello
I haven't gotten the bone turn yet what
ah come on what is that
Oh gun time ooh wow I said Oh balls
buzz buzz is how I died boom all right
now I have met my demise I didn't
realize it would be a friggin dog there
you know what no you didn't sit ah Wow
Nick steady all right
yep
yup you okay I know it yeah that's right
we are forever in your debt huh thank
you enough okie dokie must get my sister
to safety but first I may know of a way
to thank you okay don't you see 203 the
combinations to 0 to 0-3 understood did
I ever mention that I'm a Master
Assassin yes so oh he's peeing Wow
that's what you get hey Brad ease
there's a meal over there I might want
to go get it now I think it was because
I was run now how in the heck did they
spot me I'm actually confused about that
it doesn't seem like that was a way for
them to get to me but I don't know wait
a minute lies lies and slander I can get
up there can I come on come come on come
come oh come on there we go
Wow yes awesome
Oh
what what has happened what oh oh I get
it
someone shot at me I don't want to go
down there alright if it's for the charm
right down there oh god that's a lot of
rats um this is gonna be bad
probably oh oh oh oh oh oh wee oh my
face ah ah come on I should have thrown
a grenade down there we do it I know her
the way you expect preferential
treatment just big nope thank you got it
alright you get me yeah 203 I got it
blue blue blue blue easy and this guy
gonna take me everybody
I screw the bone charm I don't even want
it I want it bad once I get
ah there you are yeah not fair
ah come on come on no not again one day
masters dozen ha ha ha ha ha Master says
what shut up doggy go dumpy dog you know
no no I don't know exactly that my
doggies in my room with my scooter
there's a doggy ah two or three thank
you Oh
ha ha ha
wait a minute oh come on oh shut up
dougie finally God that took forever oh
man save my game often well how dare you
insider himself let me see hang on one
second I got to figure out what like I
can't save game what's quicksave sure
cut I'm going good quick access there's
no quick safe it's lies it's five
attributes by which II hope
the righteous you say where he waits
head open I'm not tire no keep moving
buddy luck oh I don't even have to kill
him
oh that's awesome I'll say my game now
so that I don't fail again yeah I was
just messing with you with all those
deaths and whatnot I was I was I was
just you know being my good old natured
self not failing up a storm
absolutely not ignore the fact that it
took me 20 minutes to just get into this
place nah ignore that fact
ignore that see just standing there haha
look painful ooh that looked painful
okay so boar anding instructions meeting
chamber okay with branding instruction
me
an alarm that would be not good to sound
did you get caught in the lockdown last
night six hour
ah search the place top to bottom you
put a nothing to eat but the swill we
hand out free of course we didn't I did
his voice get all Diane manly like one
time one okay I got to see you how to do
this job a session okay press ah it was
plot to break him out of gold
Richard we OOP heretic brand blah blah
blah heinous acts applied to the foot
like the forehead sends of the recipient
chemical compounds act immediately
scarring the heretic for the remainder
of life should be strapped down heretic
brand is stored in same room okay that's
clear enough alright
the one man fear throughout the end now
hang on let me see let me see their
heretic brand found in the interrogation
room let's see ah interesting
you can excommunicate the high overseer
interesting so if I didn't want to kill
him I could just excommunicate him left
a trail of hauntings and the way he's
ours
thanks we owe
oh whoops he didn't see me but he
definitely saw the body I failed in that
round see I was try to get in the window
so I could get up there but really then
that was a no-go ah whoops
I gotta get a deal with this
let's see switch poison to Campbell's
side
ah that'll work I mean technically I
want to kill this guy I'm a bit more of
the murdery stabby stab type like even
when I was playing fable I could never
be full-on you know nice some people
just really really deserve to die okay
so now that I did that I switched it to
hiya McCarthy er wait for him to enter
oh ja puppy charlie hi okay so I just
gotta wait for him Steve here I should
have saved before I did that but
whatever you know it's all the same
while we're waiting I'm gonna go let my
dog you out so I'll be right back
while this happened you all take a look
at this what what what happened why
we're going on what happened hello uh uh
what happened Curnow was rescued how huh
huh huh huh
ha ha objective completed
huh I need to go whoa
okay all right um good job me I totally
plan to do whatever I just did okay so
now I got to go find the high overseer
and murder him
hi the body good interrogation room key
I'd like that make it that where's the
interrogation room ah no no don't find
me I don't find me run up i'ma go out
there huh
oops yeah anything you saw nothing
nothing did you see anything
are you staring that way of all the ways
he could be staring of all the things
you could be looking at why not we are I
need to go downstairs but first I really
want to find this interrogation room cuz
then I could brand his forehead all
right fine I guess I can't
I know it's behind that guy who hello
bad move hums life well yeah
rogue me murdery yes I didn't ask for
this hello hey how is he down there
where did it go where the heck did it go
ah cuz again stab you just so she'd Abby
right now what's going on
get in see anything fine she did really
that time is it that time again hi I
blockin Frick and frack copper loud
bulletin Asst ah carryin more ammo time
to use it I suppose I don't wanna worry
what
take money hell yeah hey like where did
he go really what I know I don't see
where he went
backyard no that's where I came in well
this guy's just standing here like a
douche oh I see he went to the kennels
huh admiring that are you
what is rather nice but haha last thing
you'll ever see it was quite beautiful
time for a boom banging sound for a boom
bang you meet up down the basement yes
where's that it's up with your eye man
hello-o meeting a consort maybe haha
yeah there we go oh so nice
what's that haha yes please
I see
listen re out there aha Oh
so tasting this let me guess hahaha oh
boy
yep this was his consort
very tasteful pictures of yourself very
nice very classy music player
oh this where's where I was oh if I had
gone into the kennel sooner I would have
been in I just didn't know it
boy do I feel stupid
all right now um just about everyone
died so that's good that's um yes good
good not bad day work you know got bad
not bad at all yeah I did good I did
good oh oh not those not link not
believe it don't give me need to make a
dramatic roof jumping us okay oh oh yeah
freerunning
it's totally Assassin's Creed right
whoop tip this asset we didn't have
magic huh miss the chain no I missed the
chain come on ah ah ah fine B oh good
I'm here I know it's not not shoot my
boom bang in just stealthily get out of
here clam it alone
cops Oh quiet and inconspicuous lack
wait what
ooh it's so tempting to get I'll just
get this one I know I prize you'd make a
concerted effort to get more of these
but who has the time
the heart can talk to me and we go whoa
hello
well oh where is it right here it's
steady wood right here oh it's right on
the floor there I'm an idiot
yep okay interesting
press J to equip bone vengeance nice
okay all right now down to the boat man
whoo plow ah finally yeah I took a bit
longer than I had hoped for but thank
you how can you tell
let me get on this chain thank you here
we go ah ah finally oh I thought that
was him that's him over there that's
that's just a that's a hunk of wood
that's that's Samuel Sammy I would never
confuse you for a hunk of wood a core
vote it's Samuel yeah I know I'm here
yeah you're actually like I'd mistake
you for something Adam in objects from
the way I hear it Campbell lived a
pretty posh life now he lives a pretty
deadlight it's not my place to say
uh-huh
men of the faith shouldn't live like
barons yeah okay you ready to go yep
sure AM yes take me back
okay let's go I'll go for a
completionist playthrough after I finish
playing for you guys meaning I'll get
all the bone charms and what hey
overall chaos no no way that's so weird
that that is that way
I was never no no did not get that but I
can't believe that my chaos is low okay
then ah oh it's so gorgeous by the way I
just got a new graphics card that is
thinking I wonder for actually seriously
everything looks much much
very very happy hello m'lady yes I saved
you uncle yes I did how are you going to
reward what I okay
oh hello baby let me are can sit Hello
Baby Alive yeah you Corvo thank you no
problem
uncle's a good man one day he'll prove
it one day you'll prove here I know you
did this for the right reasons
yeah I did it this is a reward oh really
it's an old heirloom one of my aunt's
gave me Oh Oh Oh give me money I guess
that's okay
fine not even a kiss gah was his world
coming to
ladies dirt lady the Admiral was right
in recruiting uh-huh yeah he was
nothing's been the same since the Lord
Regent took power yeah but at least
Campbell's gone and my uncle let truly
ad and leave the world's a better place
now you know you're looking on the up
and up should live you know celebrate
yeah fine fine
alright oh here we go it's so pretty
it's so pretty is all getting real Oh
mother you did it I did down how you
took down the high overseer Campbell
against the odds uh-huh I knew you were
army I know I am but Campbell gone we've
hurt the Lord Regent and measured uh-huh
and with Martin back we'll have the
finest strategist on water
well high up there the Lord Regent must
be [ __ ] himself in dumb oil town
yeah okay five head and Campbell's
Journal that's nothing
thanks tubby yeah I'm the grid in these
encoded pages the location and condition
of emily kaldwin can be discovered
uh-huh uh her entire movement will mean
nothing if we can't place the rightful
heir on the throne
good job good job fast no doubt the Lord
Regent is holding Emily somewhere not to
reveal her to step out as the hero
further cemented regions oh did I get
the blacks and bring the younger four
soon there will be infighting on us as
to who should succeed the Empress yes
time is against us but now you should
take a well-earned rest court no I don't
think so I for the contents of the high
overseers Journal and share them with
you later
okay I must have gotten in not yes there
are things I'd like to do first yeah I
just can't get over the art direction of
this game it's just so gorgeous very
very very very very gorgeous art I don't
want to talk to you I want to talk to
this guy can I do service to you yes you
can mr. douche here we go put up Jessie
and upgrades and can I get oh that's not
your that's not your thing is it mask
optics hmm not what I want crossbow
accuracy combat sleep Dart
ooh that sounds good maybe I cannot
murder everybody maybe just maybe I
cannot kill everyone I see but you never
know you know these things
ah hey you came to find me there is
something to you is yeah I know went and
spanked the high overseer own house okay
I hope the tools I designed for you
function uh-huh yeah okay you're talking
I'm going hey don't slam the door in my
face I'm going to leave - tell me you
don't know huh I was never in service
that's not an excuse you need to learn
the big biggie Gorham the Hound pits has
seen a few lords and ladies in his day
okay they were here I expect they didn't
want to be recognized sir no uh-uh
Lord Pendleton ought to be shown the
respect he did okay whatever that's
boring does I'm going to sleep so I can
get along to the next mission
excuse me mr. Corvo coming through
champion of the Assassin's Guild or
whatever you want to call it
uh-uh so tired yeah I'll go to sleep now
ah learn about the weepers am i back in
magic fairy tale land again is that
where I am hello magic fairy tale down
no this isn't right it's wrong it's all
wrong I'm gonna steal this thank you
very much let's see huh give me what I
just sort through all your belongings
thank you for the money let's see this
looks good
let's see you like that uh-huh good read
take that got that oil yeah looks good
knowing something Master Assassin yep
let's see here
huh looks as nice Oh whale oil I'm not
baby sea oh yeah I hope no one's gonna
miss these and
it is every citizens oh.what report is
priceless
oh we couldn't turn necks for them yeah
y'all take that so uh huh in case you
can't dismiss me God went through the
books this morning and found five
mistakes you've made
yeah very well you're lucky I found them
before the Admiral did uh-huh okay
boring
downstairs I just stole everyone's
belonging Master Assassin hey we're okay
Oh Holden uh-huh okay here we go
ah here we go tell me what to do who's
my next target hello corporal hello
Beck Martin will be joining us shortly I
don't care about him I hate to start
your day with such a strange matter well
yeah the servants heard something last
night yeah I'm through the storm drains
beneath the building uh-huh most likely
a weeper poor bastard who there's no
hope for them once the play gets that
far long uh-huh nothing more than a
shuffling corpse full of sickness and
insects you're asking me yeah I'd
appreciate you investigating just to be
sure it's not a nosy Guardsman that's
getting too close I said someone I could
remember their hatches I tend to servant
them but they die of fear on the spot on
the thing what about Japan's a zero can
concoct some sort of sleep poison for
your crossbow if you want to go then
nope I'm pretty sure I don't that's
exactly the opposite of what I do
normally
and the obligatory sewer level has begun
this is get out my good old knife here
doh
just in case I don't know if I'll need
to use it but I might as a precaution
against those who might be trying to
harm me whew hello ah good old
engineered wrench over there oh it's
that wide a minute wait a minute what
cut it what you have a opening to the
sewer rifle really I caught that
automatically why didn't I catch it
automatically laughs son why did it make
me die I don't want to oh my boots my
nice hi help hey buddies hey hey lady is
that a lady I don't wanna kill lady Oh
put you aah whoosh Oh what was that you
look so tired
oh sorry yeah ok can I get back now
all right I won't I don't I'm not a
complete murdering psychopath I won't
murder like just innocent people there
it's cruel and unusual ai ai ai I am a
man of honor and dignity and respect
something like that I oh wait on oh come
on
gotta get out of the other way okay yeah
so you have this whole time and just no
not that biggity come on automatically
Auto magically get up yeah yeah there
you go
hello baby yeah you went down there in
the sewer yes I did I thought I heard a
weeper in there early uh-huh yeah you're
probably the bravest man I've ever met
yeah Martin is right hmm he's with
Admiral Havelock now they want to talk
to you okay okay here we go blue let's
talk to these lovely gentlemen over here
Corvo uh-huh I trust you remember Martin
yes here before and perhaps again
someday soon yes I owe you thanks for my
rescue hi no problem you've given us a
glimmer of hope
ah because we've gotten what we wanted
from Campbell's journey you've done yes
we know where emily kaldwin is being
helped mm-hmm the golden cat of all
places a bathhouse for aristocrats a
little better than a person dry but
there's an unfortunate twist okay it
appears that Pendleton's own kinsmen
stand in our way
ah twins Morgan and Custis okay not only
are they controlling Emily but they have
the controlling parliamentary votes we
so desperately need okay yes
the Pendleton's have to die yeah most
importantly Emily must be brought here
safely
okay protect her yeah that hold the Lord
Regent and his entourage have been dealt
with you mean by me Hey waiting for you
on the dock okay he's asked to brief you
person okay hello five head I'm up yeah
whatever I've asked to speak to you
myself
Oh God can't see Dobson Berryhill my old
it's gigantic they're horrible men it's
true as you may have heard cruel beyond
words uh-huh
further my brothers our close allies to
the Lord Regent uh-huh as long as they
are in Parliament we cannot gather the
votes we'll need to stop the Lord Regent
from further consolidating his power
right these days they're best known for
exploring their favor with him to cheat
others out of their wealth mm-hmm let's
just say that not every family victim in
quarantine for having the plague
actually has the play no I warned my
brothers in every way I could I really
did but they never did listen to me
mm-hmm they'll be at the Golden Cap
tonight at their usual revels yeah I'm
gonna murder him dead by the city watch
so it'll be dangerous everyone's gonna
die oh please do it before I change my
mind don't have to tell me twice I'm
gonna kill your brother's dead I'm gonna
stab them in their neck and then their
heart and then up their butt and no way
maybe not that sounds wrong it sounded
pretty wrong I'm just gonna stab in the
heart in the neck if that's okay golden
crap when you're ready uh-huh I've taken
Lord Pendleton enough times believe me
yeah all right let's go OOP whee Oh
hello I don't actually know what this
mask does for me besides hide my
identity I mean suppose it looks kind of
cool maybe I've always been one for
fashion
I'll get you as close as I can to the
golden cat or about
I have to go rest away okay the entrance
is near hold the square
oh my favorite place to be Emily gets
back all safe and sure sounds good of a
I'm to Pendleton severe son yes not be a
lot of guards and a lot of murders
slackjaw might have some ideas on
everything get inside the cat oh I know
how don't kill you oh wait Lions
territory
he and his bottle street gang all up in
yo dunwall whiskey factor uh-huh they
sell the elixir that folks used to fight
off sounds like Tom and I will complete
an eye out for you and a little lady to
bring them back
mm-hmm good luck to you I know Emily
must mean a lot to you yeah I suppose um
we played hide and seek one sweet Corvo
a river hand I know pulled up alongside
me last night sighs one of those watch
towers on clamoring now okay I guess you
getting rid of Campbell shook up the
Lord Regent sounds good to me
god it's so gorgeous I can't stand how
great this game hello
your actions affect the city a high
number of deaths results in more rats
and weepers different reactions from
your allies and darker final outcomes oh
all right
okay ah that doesn't sound good
I suppose I should be nicer well hello
what the hell's going on whoa
holy crap is that the watchtower thing
damn anyway that's gonna have to wait
until the next episode I am actually all
out of time god I love this game hannes
game is fantastic so thank you all so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye